in the Australian wasteland of Mad Max
things have gone into post-apocalyptic
ultraviolent overdrive if you plan on
taking it on here's five things you can
do to save yourself from becoming food
for the crows speaking of food the first
rule of the post apocalypse is pretty
consistent across all its iterations
that is keep an eye on your resources as
you can imagine food and water are
pretty scarce around the raider filled
desert plains
although gas is in pretty decent supply
for some reason because video games that
said you will want to make sure you
always have an extra can of gas stashed
in your car the magnum opus so you don't
get stranded should you want your
driving adventures to last more than a
day or two you'll also need to get your
hands on some health replenishing food
and water within the wasteland a murder
of crows and yes that is the correct and
terrifying way to refer to a group of
crows will indicate where you can find
food and buy food I of course mean the
maggots and burdens that you can
liberate from decomposing corpses for a
quick and healthy snack on dog food you
can also eat dog food just like in the
movies once you've had your fill of
tasty treats you should consider making
like a reboot Lara Croft and start
collecting scrap and operating your
stuff some of the wasteland is mapped
out and other parts can be discovered by
riding up in hot-air-balloon outposts to
spotting your objectives and location
then there's the so called big nothing
there's no food out there and it's all
uncharted but that's where you'll get
rare parts for your car when it comes to
taking out falls without the use of your
tire treads however you'll want to make
sure you have reliable weapons on hand
while the shotgun is Max's old faithful
it's a good idea to mainly make use of
Malay weapons since as my dad always
used to say a sword can't run
ammo save up those rare shotgun shells
for the toughest foe and take on regular
scum with one of the unique Malay
weapons you'll find lying around enemy
camps or your bare hands one of the main
narrative and gameplay focuses in Mad
Max is going to revolve around building
up your car and magnum opus Max's iconic
holden v8 interceptor has gone missing
in the game so you'll have to get comfy
with this new vehicle and work to
transform it into a machine just as
little driving is a pretty significant
portion of the game 60% in fact
according to the devs so you'll want to
make sure you have a handle on it um
totally intended there are over a dozen
kind to car upgrades you can apply
simultaneously which will have positive
and negative impacts on staff including
handling boost grinding weaponry speed
and acceleration as well as attack and
defense and just like any good driving
game you'll want to balance these to
best suit your personal skills and style
I for example am known to lose control
of my virtual car and spin out while
driving down a straight road so handling
is a must next you'll have to decide on
what you think is the best strategy for
clearing out the deadly wasteland Mad
Max does have stealth elements like
Silent Knight takedowns and the option
to take out stronghold perimeter
defenses with a sniper rifle you can
also do the open-world thing of scouting
ahead with your binoculars to identify
threats in enemy camps before you get
too close
realistically though you'll probably end
up falling into a strategy that's either
chaos or even more care what you can
also do however is complete side
missions like races or time trials to
down the threat level for the region
which will make exploring a tad safer or
you know just kill everybody your call
fortunately all your enemies attended
the Batman villain school of let's take
turns finding him even though there's 12
of us so you can always leverage that
finally the wasteland might be a place
full of deadly storms and dudes that
want to kill you but that doesn't mean
you can't get a little help from your
friends it turns out that not pointing
your gun at wasteland well as you don't
want to turn you into a gory hood
ornaments can be a pretty great idea
should you so choose you can establish
friendly relations with some strongholds
throughout the wasteland converting
enemy strongholds and filling them with
allies will ultimately net you more
quests rewards and benefits like having
a nearby refuge from storms as well as
periodic scrap drops let me know if
you'll be playing Mad Max and how you
plan to go about it down in that comment
box if you want to get a better look at
the game before you drop your hard
earned dollars on it you can check out
our now playing episode on GameSpot
uh I'm gonna go ahead and say this is my
favorite way to kill a guy oh oh boy
chips chips